The blame game within
the Republican Party
is already in full swing,
and a majority of fingers
right now
seem to be pointing in one direction
at former President Trump.
So the big question
is, will Tuesday's
election debacle
actually jeopardize
his hold over the party
in a way that none of this did?
When you were a star, they let y
You can do anything.
You also had people that were
very fine people on both sides.
But he just said it's not Russia
I will say this.
I don't see any reason why it wo
It's one conversation that I had
with the president of Ukraine
that was perfect,
that I see the disinfectant
where it knocks it out in a minu
One minute
we're going to walk down
and I'll be there with you.
We're going to walk down to the
because you'll never take back
our country with weakness.
You have to show strength
of all of that to say there's be
that has been going on with Trum
and not even a violent insurrect
on the Capitol really prompted
lasting, you know, recrimination
for him.
And also
now it seems to me
that the issue isn't so much
what Republican leaders think.
It's really what Republican vote
Yes.
If Republicans
finally pull away from Trump,
it'll be because they believe
that the base is no longer with
that they believe he
no longer
is politically advantageous for
I don't know if that's
going to actually be the case.
If past is Prolog, maybe we won'
But we have started to see some
at least behind the scenes
with a lot of finger
pointing at Donald Trump.
But at the same time,
you still have
a lot of MAGA voices out there
now trying to blame Mitch McConn
You have Elise Stefanik,
the number three Republican
coming out and endorsing his 24
So I'm not sure there is going t
a full out reckoning just yet.
We'll have to wait and see.
Yeah, it feels like
the whiplash is already happenin
and tough on Trump.
Yeah. I mean, you wrote in the i
Politico the Trump backlash
may already be fading.
Yeah. Yeah.
I seen this movie before.
Actors Hollywood, and we absolut
I mean, look,
the Murdoch empire obviously cam
conservative leaning media
pointing the finger at Trump.
You saw gun rights groups say
that their voters or their membe
they're no longer looking at Tru
They're looking at dissents.
You saw people like Chris
Christie go on the record and sa
this is all because of Trump.
We lost
we're losing big because of Trum
But you're already seeing people
just mentioned in the Senate.
The public conversation in Congr
now is not about Trump
being a problem with the party.
It's about
these conservatives in MAGA, Rep
pointing the finger
at their own leadership,
people like Rick Scott,
people like Ted
Cruz saying McConnell is the bla
or McCarthy is the blame, etc.
And so if that sort of come to
Jesus moment is going to happen,
it's clearly not happening
yet in Congress
where leadership
is currently being blamed No.
One,
you know,
one of the things
about Trump and Republicans,
this is the problem, right?
They their base loves him.
The midterm election sorry, not
Independent voters
see things
like this troop
social post that he did this wee
Young Ken.
Now that's an interesting
take sounds Chinese
doesn't it in Virginia
couldn't have won without me.
That's a reference to Virginia G
Glenn Youngkin using basically a
attack against him.
Those are the kinds of things
that independent voters
seem to be saying.
Enough already. Absolutely.
But it's
it's the path through these prim
that that is this horrible
track for a team normal Republic
it let's face it in Arizona.
Trump's problem is he
he crushes their recruiting effo
to get candidates who can win Ar
They could have had Doug
Ducey as the governor.
The governor could have run for
Chris
obviously would have won the Sen
if he had run in New Hampshire.
In Georgia,
they had several different peopl
who they could have run, said
of Herschel Walker.
Doug Collins
would have been a much better
statewide candidate.
But Trump crushes all of them
and you end up instead
with the Blake Masters types and
and until they figure out
how to get him to either
just stay out of these primaries
you know,
they're 20, 24
should be a big year for them.
But if they end up
with another set of Blake Master
as their candidates,
they might not win again.
And hey, by the way,
Trump is going to be
you know, he's
announcing a presidential bid on
He's he wants to be on the ballo
in 2024.
And the question
now is he's been attacking
Ron DeSantis
he's been attacking Glenn
Youngkin two people who might
pose a challenge to him in a pri
But the question is,
will other Republicans
who maybe don't feel Trump shoul
center stage step up?
Here's a tweet from Mike
Pompeo
this week that seemed to be a li
of like a sub tweet, if you will
Conservatives are elected
when we deliver,
not when we just rail on social
Not really sure who he's referri
Maybe he's referring to, maybe h
But it seems emblematic.
A lot of Republicans
want to push Trump away,
but are not willing to actually
do it themselves.
Yeah, and I think the problem
for problems
for Republicans
that the problems Republicans
face extend beyond Trump.
It's not only Trump.
Some of the policy positions
that Republicans
championed are just not in line
with what most where most Americ
So that is an issue.
But on Trump, I mean,
the former vice president
is somewhat right.
Look, at Governor Kemp.
Governor Kemp,
you know, faced
an onslaught of attacks from
from the former president,
but he remained focused on deliv
for his conservative base.
If you are deeply conservative
and kind of just ignore him,
there is evidence
that it can work out for
I mean, look at Ron DeSantis.
I mean, he's
basically been ignoring the Trum
the question is, how long can he
Yeah.
I mean, especially Trump
is just going to continue
to go after him.
And as for that Pompeo tweet,
I mean, yes, underlining meaning
But he didn't even name Trump.
I mean, come on,
you're going to need a lot more
to take out Trump than that.
And if all these
if all these Republicans
have the same thought process
that we've seen,
that Trump is very weak after th
midterm cycle
and they all jump in,
I mean, he's going to
still keep that core base of 30%
and then the rest of the Republi
could maybe be divided
among Christie Pompeo all the
which is what happened in 2016
and then we see the repeat of hi
Yeah.
And the Trump team is certainly
it will be a repeat of that hist
they've already said it
publicly
they think that this is just 201
all over again
and he's just going to knock
each and every one of them out.
We'll see how that how
the establishment
so so to speak learns
from what happened then.
But coming up next for us
eight vindicated.
President Biden takes a victory
What Tuesday's results mean
for his next
two years in the White House.